[Music]
my name is Jim Leakey and I'm going to
show you how to make a delicious loaf of
sourdough bread at home and only a
couple of hours we have a little bit of
sourdough starter here so I got to weigh
out about 100 grams I'm going to add to
this 230 grams of water and then I'm
going to whisk those two together like
stuff so the sourdough starter is a
little piece of sourdough with flour and
water and then it begins to ferment
spontaneously naturally in a separate
bowl I'm going to add my dry ingredients
like so and in this case I got some
white flour and I got some whole wheat
flour because I like the flavors but the
whole wheat gives the bread and then I'm
going to add a little bit of salt as
well and then I'm going to mix it all
together it's like this with my hand and
now I'm going to add the mixture of the
water with the starter and then I'm
going to mix it together very very
quickly very loosely like this just
until it comes together you don't need
to mix it any more than this and then
take your scraper and scrape down any of
the remaining dough and you're going to
let it sit for about a half an hour for
its first rest prepare or work surface
with some flour carefully remove the
dough and place it on the flour and form
it loosely into a ball fold up the dough
this like this and
how to pull it together without ripping
it or tearing it very important to be
very gentle with the dough and then I
have here a pan with some parchment
paper and then very conveniently I have
some wheat friend if you don't know what
we friend is it's the ingredients and we
do take the dough place it on the pan
and then cover it with a towel a little
bit more of bread on top and about an
hour and a half two hours the dough
should be leavened enough a half an hour
before the bread is ready pre-heat your
oven with a cast-iron pot or baking
cloche and I've got my dough that's been
leavening for about two and a half hours
now and I'm going to lift it up by the
edges except place it on the pot takes a
serrated preferably a serrated knife
give it one long score and then take the
pot quickly put it on top of the
preheated pan places in the oven at 500
degrees for a half an hour
that's Oh half now we're going to remove
the parchment paper and then allow it to
continue baking for another ten minutes
so here we have our big whole-wheat
sourdough bread with bake for about 40
minutes so this is about a 1 pound loaf
of bread
more or less I hope you get a chance to
make it yourself at home
wocka wocka wocka wocka wocka wocka
wocka welcome
[Music]